[Música]
con estás
quien no tiene fuerza para sostener un
sueño no tendrá fuerza para sostener su
vida hermosísima frase que le escuché
decir al maestro sergio jiménez mi
maestro mi amigo de tantos años durante
décadas a nuestros alumnos de actuación
una frase que escuche y se me quedó de
verdad prendado en mi corazón
de qué están hechos los sueños los
sueños de cada uno de nosotros si en
este momento todos ustedes ahí sentados
o los que nos escuchan piensan he tenido
estos sueños de que materia están hechos
cuando se han cumplido
porque de repente no podemos cumplirlos
y pienso yo en el caso mío como a veces
poder pedirle a alguien que tenga un
sueño como por ejemplo yo cuando tenía
12 años y era una niña y había visto
sufrir a mi mamá una enfermedad que
había durado casi un año y había en ese
momento
tenido una de las más terribles
oportunidades que puede tener un ser
humano ver morir a una madre a un padre
supongo yo que de los seres más amados
que uno puede tener en la vida después
vienen los hijos pero en ese momento el
ser más amado de tu vida a los 12 años
vi a doña celia gonzález flores mi mama
exhalar el último suspiro
a ver cómo se iba la vida de su cuerpo
como pedirle a esa niña de 12 años que
estaba viendo cómo moría su mamá que
tuviera un sueño ella murió el 27 de
abril de 1968 en un día soleado precioso
y yo recuerdo que a esa edad me salía al
patio de la casa de mi abuela y miraba
el sol y desea no debería de haber sol
no tienen por qué cantar los pájaros no
tiene por qué haber nada ninguna alegría
después de algo tan devastador como
haber visto morir a mi mamá
como pedirle a una joven a una jovencita
que se embaraza y que por ser madre
soltera pierde su apellido porque su
papá no quiere que él y mamás en su casa
ni siquiera la línea barraza quería que
fuera yo reconocida como una persona
verdad como pedirle a alguien a esa
jovencita que tuvo que ver cómo podía
alimentar a su hija porque de repente no
tenía ni siquiera
cubiertas las tres grandes cosas que
necesita un ser humano simple y
sencillamente casa vestir el sustento
como pedirle a alguien que tenga un
sueño cuando se tiene que salir de la
escuela porque ni siquiera tiene para
subirse al camión para irse a la escuela
como pedirle entonces
que se vaya a pie a la universidad a ver
si encuentra un amigo que le preste 350
que era lo que costaba un gerber para
poder alimentar a su hija como pedirle a
una mujer joven que ha tenido que
trabajar y tener que salirse de su
escuela
para después ver de qué manera tratar de
llevar a su hija lo más dignamente
posible como
tuve que trabajar vendiendo libros tuve
que trabajar en un salón de belleza sé
hacerlo todo y eso me salió a todo dar
porque sé hacer bases supe hacer uñas de
acrílico se cortara el pelo
y tenía que trabajar duramente porque
había veces que no tenía para comer como
pedirle a alguien desde un cuarto de
azotea que tenga sueños
como pedirle a una mujer finalmente esta
mujer que tiene la oportunidad
maravillosa
de ser nominada a uno de los premios más
importantes que pueda tener un actor en
el mundo el oscar yo tuve 17
nominaciones como actriz por la película
babel 17 nominaciones norteamericanas
pero llegar a ser nominada para un oscar
es lo más grande que puede pensar un
actor un director o alguien del espacio
escénico
yo recuerdo que para toda esa
experiencia que fue desde cannes hasta
el oscar pues mi esposo y yo no teníamos
una economía muy eficiente que digamos
entonces afortunadamente siempre
contamos con los outlets y con los
mercados donde yo siempre digo que
existe algo que parece que
gracias a dios
y en esa vorágine maravillosa donde te
ves envuelto en algo que nunca te
hubieras imaginado en donde vienen
actores y actrices famosísimos que tú
has admirado únicamente en la pantalla o
en las revistas y vienen y te abrazan y
te dicen eres maravilloso él es
fantástico eres soberbio dios mío
por suerte
me daba cuenta en ese momento que no era
adriana barraza a la que rezaban
avanzaban a amelia a mi personaje porque
se habían conmovido con su historia y
era lo que veían en mi admirado en mi
trabajo y eso lo agradecía pero no a mí
no me conocían eso me permitió
afortunadamente nunca despegar mis pies
de la tierra que es muy difícil cuando
uno se encuentra ante un evento de tanta
fama
y llegará entonces al maravilloso
momento la ceremonia del oscar
vestidos preciosos joyas costosísimas
que no son de nosotros eso sí les quiero
decir usualmente las huellas y los
vestidos a algún gran diseñador de los
presto
y tú los tendrás que regresar
a veces te los regalan pero no siempre
así que entonces en esa hermosísima
ceremonia en esa fantástica ceremonia
estar sentada enfrente de jennifer lópez
nicole kidman junto a mí mi esposo y
después gael garcía diego luna más atrás
gonzález iñárritu y una cantidad una
cantidad de latinoamericanos y de
mexicanos especialmente nominados y
todos en la gran fiesta la gran
ceremonia del oscar
como pedirle a esa mujer que tuviera paz
y calma en su corazón porque yo les
quiero confesar tenía todo el deseo de
ser como esas grandes luminarias que yo
había visto durante tantos años en las
ceremonias de los oscar es esas mujeres
regias esas actrices preciosas que
cuando pasaban su rostro ya se hacían
muy calmadamente y yo decía yo quiero
ser así yo también quiero verme en esa
pantalla de esa forma tan majestuosa y
qué es lo que sucede entonces en esa
gran ceremonia cuando empiezan a nombrar
a las personas nominadas a las mujeres
nominadas me sentía tan emocionada de
pensar que esa niña que había perdido a
su mamá en la ciudad de toluca que esa
niña que había trabajado tan duro que
esa niña que había soñado con ese
momento
que había pasado tantas tantas de verdad
tantas privaciones que habían tratado de
llevar a su hija por el mejor camino
posible
estaba en ese momento con la posibilidad
de ganarse un oscar
y entonces en ese momento veo que pasan
una escena de la película babel y luego
veo mi rostro un rostro que estaban
viendo en todo el mundo
y yo salgo tan emocionada que comienzo a
suspirar y comienzo a querer llorar yo
dije si ya no fui y
ya no me vi como todas las actrices que
yo hubiera querido de verdad emular no
era una mexicana que estaba ahí siendo
nominada en un lugar que a lo mejor ni
siquiera le correspondía
y entonces el gran momento la música
majestuosa y entonces el gran actor muy
reconocido dice y la ganadora es otra
que no es adriana barraza
10 después porque di muchas entrevistas
aunque pierdas igual sigues dando muchas
entrevistas hubo un reportero
norteamericano que me preguntó que si te
usted cuando no ganó
se vale todo tipo de preguntas y yo le
dije sabe usted señor mire usted
recuerda cuando era el niño y entonces
le habían comprado un globo precioso
esos nuevos que no va a mamá mamá papá
ese es el globo y entonces viene usted
en la calle con su globo hermoso rojo de
preferencia precioso volando en el sitio
de pronto
se me fue
así me sentí
cuando no me gane ese premio
y me di cuenta que
a veces quienes podemos ser más
devastadores para
matar machacar destruir nuestros sueños
somos nosotros mismos porque
inmediatamente en ese momento me
llegaron frases a mi mente que decían y
de veras te creíste que te podías ganar
un oscar tú en serio en sí yo creía que
podía llegar a ser esa actriz que
signará unos
fue terrible
y lo único que sentí en esos segundos
fue vergüenza
me daba vergüenza de haber creído
siquiera que yo era digna de haberme
podido tener ese premio cuando de pronto
sentí la mano de mi esposo
fuerte con su amor por qué
y lo miré y vi un hombre que me apoyaba
con todo su amor y en ese momento dije
sí es cierto yo tengo a mi esposo tengo
a mi hija tengo a mi nieto tengo amigos
tengo a mis hermanos yo soy rica de
verdad se los juro que eso fue lo que yo
sentí vi el rostro de gael el rostro de
diego en el comercial se pararon todos
los compañeros y me abrazaban y decían
no importa no importa estar bien
denominada ya pasa hasta la historia
porque me lo dijeron y me reí primero
dije ah no si cierto si pase a la
historia o sí pues sí es cierto ya quedó
anotado verdad
y después la gran capital la gran actriz
llegó me abrazó y me dijo esto nos sirve
sería un honor para mí trabajar contigo
eso me decían y después en la fiesta de
vanity fair- me abrazaban y grandes
actores
y entonces ahí me pude dar cuenta que
uno solamente a veces ve una parte de su
propia historia y no ve la otra
y puedo decir que esa niña que vio morir
a su mamá en medio de su gran gran dolor
no faltó a alguien que la abrazara
porque siempre hay alguien a veces
sentimos y pensamos que estamos
completamente solos pero no es cierto
las platicas de todos mis compañeros nos
hacen ver y la mía también que no es
cierto
porque esa joven que no tenía casa
porque su papá decidió que no estaba
bien que viviera con él y la familia
barraza también y tuvo a alguien que le
abrió las puertas la familia de su mamá
sus hermanos la familia aliar que me
abrió sus puertas mi gran amiga con
quien yo viví porque esa niña que no
tuvo para darle de comer a su hija y que
se tuvo que ir caminando a la
universidad encontró un amigo que llegó
ahí a la entrada de la universidad y
sacó dinero y se lo dio porque esa mujer
que a veces no tenía para comer siempre
tuvo a alguien que le echara la mano
siempre entonces
yo pienso de verdad los sueños son
solamente cosas grandes los sueños son
pensar que a lo mejor puedo llegar a ser
presidente o tener el oscar
y me di cuenta que los sueños a veces
pueden ser tan minúsculos pero tan
gigantes como por ejemplo tener la
bendición de poner la cabeza en la
almohada y dormir tranquilo
poder despertarse y respirar después de
sobrevivir un infarto y dos veces cáncer
puedo decir que mi sueño es ese momento
en que no puedo abrir los ojos y puedo
decir estoy sana tengo vida ese momento
cuando mi hija me abraza cuando mi nieto
dice tu abuela
ese momento ese momento cuando mi esposo
está conmigo siempre ese momento cuando
mis alumnos me miran y me dicen gracias
maestra me encantó la clase ese momento
esos pequeños momentos este momento
frente a ustedes donde dije mi sueño es
que esta charla me salga bonita para
poder decirles a ustedes lo que quiero
porque estoy convencida de verdad se los
digo con mi corazón que esos pequeños
sueños van formando un camino grandísimo
al gran sueño
porque he comprobado que quien no tiene
fuerza para sostener un sueño no tendrá
fuerza para sostener su vida gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]